JONATHAN BERI: Hi, and welcome
to this week's Google
Developers Live.
My name is Jonathan Beri.
I'm a developer advocate
for Google+.
And with me is--
JOANNA SMITH: I'm Joanna Smith,
and I'm a developer
programs engineer.
And I'm really happy to be
kicking off 2013 Google+
Developers Live.
JONATHAN BERI: Awesome.
Yes it is.
It's also a kickoff up for
our new platform--
the next generation of the
Google+ Platform, and a major
leap for developers.
Today we introduce Google+
Sign-in, which is a simple and
secure way for users to sign
into your apps, both on the
web and in mobile.
Leveraging the power of Google+,
integrating it deeply
applications, as well as some
other magic that we are
introducing with this release.
So we're super excited
about it.
JOANNA SMITH: It's
really cool.
And to show you guys-- so you
can visualize how this is
going to look-- we actually have
a demo that we wanted to
show you to kick off
today's episode.
And the most important thing
to notice as we go to our
website is the shiny,
red button.
We're very proud of our Sign-in
with Google button.
JONATHAN BERI: So we have
a quick link here.
JOANNA SMITH: And so
when you go to--
as a developer, you can offer
this button in your app, on
mobile-- iOS, or Android--
or on your website.
And any user can just come to
your site like normal, see the
button, and decide to connect
their profile, which will open
an authentication dialog where
they can enter their
credentials.
Or if they're already logged
in to Google, they can just
continue with the
authorization.
What's really great about this
dialogue, though, is it makes
it very clear for the user
to see how they can
control their privacy.
JONATHAN BERI: So I have
this dialogue open.
Why don't you walk us through
what we're seeing right now?
JOANNA SMITH: So there's
a list of every bit of
information that an
application is
asking for the user.
And they can actually control
not only which friends are
going to see their app activity,
but which friends
that app can see.
So if a user decides to regulate
that, they can
actually choose which circles
gets sent to that app.
And maybe restrict it down.
So maybe they have some people
in their circles that they
don't necessarily want being
involved with them on this
application, because it's
just not relevant.
And they can control that.
JONATHAN BERI: So I'm going to
remove my family circle, just
because they don't take
really good pictures.
JOANNA SMITH: Yeah,
they're terrible.
And then we're going to--
and then you can also control
which circles get to see any
content generated by this
app, which is great.
If you maybe don't necessarily
want to share photos with your
sister, because she likes
to steal them all--
so we'll go ahead and
take her out.
JONATHAN BERI: And these are
called App Activities.
JOANNA SMITH: And it also makes
it really easy for you
to decide you don't want
to share anything.
And you can go ahead at
the very top level
and choose Only Me.
And I think that's a really
powerful thing for the user.
And it makes it really easy for
the developer, because you
don't have to do anything
to allow this.
JONATHAN BERI: And one great use
case for users-- and why
we provide this as
a clear option--
is if a particular application
is for your personal use.
Maybe it's a fitness
application.
And you may not want to share
all the activities you're
doing within that fitness
application, but you do want
that record.
This is a great option for
those type of users.
JOANNA SMITH: So it's really
great altogether.
And then once they actually
authenticate, we have a really
powerful option where if you
have an Android device, you
can auto-install the application
on the user's
Android phone just by
having them log in.
JONATHAN BERI: And this
is from the website.
We're not going to a
different store to
initiate this process.
This is from Photo Hunt's
application.
JOANNA SMITH: It's the same pop
up that they're already
seeing to continue
their login.
And they can just choose right
now-- oh, yeah, I do want this
on my phone.
This is really simple.
They don't have to search
through the Play store.
They don't have to go through
any extra hoops.
It's right there, and
it's really simple.
So let's go ahead and add
it to our demo account.
JONATHAN BERI: So I'm going
to hit install.
It says it's downloading.
JOANNA SMITH: So while that
downloads, we'll go ahead and
look at the website.
Now if you notice the demo
account is signed in-- it's
personalized.
We've got the profile picture.
We've got their name.
You can welcome them
to the site.
And then you can also
show them their
friends along the side.
We have a list of friends
are also using this app.
JONATHAN BERI: So this is
actually a new feature that
we've introduced with
the sign-in button.
JOANNA SMITH: Friend's list--
the list of people in
a circle has not
previously been available.
It's important to note that
this is still a flat list.
You cannot see the user's
actual circles.
But you can see who they've
included in
their social sphere.
JONATHAN BERI: That's super
powerful to make social proof
as part of your application.
JOANNA SMITH: Definitely.
And it can help you if you also
have support for a social
graph within your
app natively.
You can start using this to
connect users that already
have accounts with you.
So let's go ahead and
go to the phone.
Is it still installing?
JONATHAN BERI: I think
it may still be--
JOANNA SMITH: Did we
get a notification?
JONATHAN BERI: We didn't.
JOANNA SMITH: Are we on Wi-Fi?
JONATHAN BERI: We're on Wi-Fi.
JOANNA SMITH: Well, let's go
ahead and talk about a
different feature while
we wait for the
internet to catch up.
So the other thing that I'm
really excited about,
personally, from this launch,
is the ability to use an
interactive post.
And this is very similar to
what we already have.
It's a share that's
been expanded to
have additional features.
So now, in addition to that
normal share [INAUDIBLE], you
might start seeing in your
stream a share with a button.
And this button has a verb--
some sort of call to action.
And that button can pull a user
from the Google+ stream
into your application.
JONATHAN BERI: So lets go ahead
and create one of these
interactive posts.
Right here, this is a
button, actually.
It's part of the application--
the Photo Hunt application.
And there's a JavaScript API, so
you can scan it and make it
integrated with your
application.
So the user flow is nice.
I did a vote.
Which, in this case, I didn't do
an interactive post, but I
can go ahead and promote it.
So why don't you tell us
what's going on here?
JOANNA SMITH: So at this, when
we're soliciting votes for our
friends as well, because we
really like this photo, we are
presented with a dialogue.
And this dialogue-- like I
said, it's built off the
existing share.
But now we've got the
button that's there.
And as a developer, you
can control that
text on that button.
You get to choose that string.
And we have, I think,
over 100 right now.
We have a lot of different
options, and we're taking more
suggestions as we move along.
The other thing that is
incredibly powerful is you can
prefill the text in the
share dialogue.
I think that's already been
done here with Photo Hunt.
So you can get the user started
with maybe what you
most want to promote from this
part of your application.
You can also prefill up
to 10 recipients.
So they won't be tagged in the
post, but they'll be directly
shared with.
So it will trigger a
notification on their end.
JONATHAN BERI: And a powerful
part of including users
already in the post.
So prefilling recipients.
Part of Google and Google+ is
our notification system.
And when you explicitly mention
a user-- or sorry,
include them in a share--
we notify them across all
Google properties.
So anywhere you see that little
red box, that will
light up for those
particular users.
Because the user who's allowing
this prefill has the
intent to actually deliver
that message.
So we have a guaranteed
delivery.
And if those recipients also
have email configured for
notifications, they'll get
an email if they're
not by their desktop.
And you can actually prefill
with email addresses.
So if those users have a Google+
but maybe not using
the app, or they haven't signed
up for Google+, yet
they'll get that user flow and
can even upgrade which is
pretty powerful to get more
users using your app.
JOANNA SMITH: What's also
powerful is that if they are
mentioned, or if the user
stumbles across your
application's interactive person
that a different user
has shared, when they click
on that, they may be
taken to your app.
But if they haven't already
signed up for your app,
they'll be taken first to an
authentication screen so that
they can sign up.
And also they can install the
application onto their phone
directly through the
identification screen, just
like before.
So there's a lot of different
entry points for a user to
make their way into your
app from the Google+.
JONATHAN BERI: So I'm going to
actually complete that share.
And so now it should
be posting.
JOANNA SMITH: I think we might
have forgotten to log into a
second demo account, but we'll
just look at it on the stream
of this one.
JONATHAN BERI: Sure.
Sure.
There we go.
This is the post we
just created.
JOANNA SMITH: So you
can see, it's
actually incredibly engaging.
Because not only can users share
something that they care
about with the people in their
circles, but now the people in
their circles are involved
in that action.
They can choose to go into the
app and create their own
shares, or maybe they can do the
same action within the app
and start interacting there.
And so I think it's a really,
really engaging way to let
your users interact.
JONATHAN BERI: And ask their
friends to join them.
That's the whole point of
an interactive post.
It's about bringing your friends
who are across Google+
into your app in a way
that they can start
interacting with it.
That's where the interactivity
comes from.
And so we saw the preview
of the interactive post.
And now this is what
users would see
on the desktop stream.
I'm going to click
on that post.
And what's happening when
I click on that post?
You see that I open
up the app.
And what's unique about
this is the URL--
that I was deep linked
back into the app.
JOANNA SMITH: So we actually
enabled the deep link
functionality last fall,
and a few of our clever
developers caught it.
But it's really, really
compelling.
Because not only is a user taken
to your app, but they're
taken into your app, to a
particular part-- a particular
photo, or maybe particular
song.
And that is the part that
they cared about.
And so they get to skip the rest
and already be involved.
And that's more likely to keep
a user in your app and grow
your user base.
JONATHAN BERI: And another
powerful thing about deep
linking is support across
all platforms.
So web, Android, iOS.
So if a user is using an Android
application and they
share it to their friends who
happen to be on a desktop, the
deep link will take the user
to that desktop version.
And now if another one of their
friends is on iOS, it
will know and will take
them to be iOS app.
JOANNA SMITH: And this is part
of the Google magic.
You don't have to initiate the
support for these different
deep links to determine which
one is the appropriate one.
We do that for you.
You just have to provide
the links.
JONATHAN BERI: And a neat thing,
especially here-- we
talked over-the-air install.
But with deep links, if a user
doesn't have your application
installed already, we will take
them to the app store.
And on Android, once they've
completed the download, we'll
take them back the deep
link that they
intended to click on.
So follow all the way through,
and you just got
a new mobile user.
JOANNA SMITH: Our goal is to
make sure that you don't lose
users along the way.
We want to make sure that they
are interested in your app.
And they make it all the way to
the point that they wanted
to be, even if they have to
detour through authentication
or installation.
So it did it ever install?
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah,
I believed in did.
JOANNA SMITH: So let's go
ahead and look at that.
And like I said, this is
really compelling.
Because they don't have to do
anything on the phone in order
to make this happened.
I chose this when I
authenticated, and now I have
a notification telling me my
download's ready to go, and I
can start using.
JONATHAN BERI: So first thing
you'll notice is that
notification.
I haven't dismissed it yet.
That is what a user would see.
So they actually get to
see the rich icons
from the Play Store.
Your service notification
is installed.
And like many apps,
it gets installed
onto your home screen.
And just to show you
that it works--
hopefully our wi-fi
is back up--
I can sign in using a native
Android sign in.
Pick the account.
And then you can see we have
that same off process.
JOANNA SMITH: And it's the
exact same dialogue.
A little more compact for the
phone, but it's all of the
same features that I
already mentioned.
It can still control both which
people in our circles
the app sees, and which app
activities are seen by people
in their circles.
It's great.
So that's Photo Hunt.
And for developers, throughout
the day we're going to be
releasing new samples to
help you get started.
And one of those is actually
the back end for
the Phone Hunt app.
And we want you to be able
to see a full end-to-end
integration.
That might help you figure out
how you can best integrate
Google+ Sign-In with
your existing app.
And so look forward to seeing
this today, and also in
multiple languages
in the future.
JONATHAN BERI: So now that
we actually saw what we
introduced today at a high
level, I just wanted to run
through, pretty quickly, all the
different features and the
way a developer might
approach it.
So things they need to know
to actually integrate.
And I have a quick deck that
goes over each piece by piece.
So Google+ Sign-in--
simplified sign-in.
The first thing to note
is that we take
privacy very seriously.
You saw with the circles picker
and app activities how
a user can control who and what
sees their activities and
their user data.
We also take revoking data and
deleting data very seriously
in our terms of service
and provide APIs to
simplify that process.
So if a user does not want
to be connected with an
application anymore we,
help and enable that.
So the developer can
facilitate that.
JOANNA SMITH: You can see this
in Photo Hunt, because after
we signed in, the Sign
Up button became
a Disconnect button.
And it was a very clear and very
obvious at the top level,
how to remove yourself
from an app.
JONATHAN BERI: And we also make
the integration pretty
easy if you have an
existing sign-in.
Really, it's just adding column
to your database,
merging with your existing
homegrown solution--
where there will be other
social networking.
And we have a bunch of showcases
on our site that
talk about the integration
process for launch partners
and how quickly they're able
to integrate with their
existing solutions.
And ultimately, this is about
giving users choice and making
it easier for you to acquire
those users.
If they have a preferred social
network, this will
basically help you onboard
than quickly and easily.
So, going to go at a little
bit of code and show you
actually what you have to
implement these features,
starting with web.
For anybody's who's used the
Google platform before, we
start out with a plug-in.
In the same fashion of our
previous plug-ins, you put a
little JavaScript on your page,
put a little bit of mark
up, and we render a stylized
and configurable button.
It's just that simple.
From that point on, we
handle the OAuth.
We handle the authorization
pop-ups.
And then you can go ahead and
integrate those tokens and
APIs within your application.
The basics is literally, you
give us a client ID that
you've created through our
Google APIs console.
Maybe requests some scopes,
like a login scope, and
activities you might
want to write.
On the Android side, it's
native to Android.
We worked with the Android team
to make sure that our STK
is comfortable and easy to
integrate for Android
developers.
So you would add the button
to your layout.
Initialize a plus client-- an
object that allows you to make
API calls, including sign in.
And then register on connected
call back.
And once that's fired, you can
go ahead and actually start
getting user data.
It's just that simple.
We have starter applications
that show how little code it
actually takes to make a
full-fledged Sign-in button.
JOANNA SMITH: And our goal this
entire time was to make
it very easy for you
to implement.
There shouldn't be a
lot of hoops and a
dance, so to speak.
We've heard feedback from
you that OAuth has been
challenging.
So we worked really hard
to make it very simple.
So look for these code snippets
throughout the
documentation.
And also look at the samples as
they become available today
to really see what's going on.
To see a full integration.
JONATHAN BERI: That's
a good point.
And moving along, we've also
done the same sort of heavy
lifting for you on iOS.
This is an SDK.
It allows you to go ahead and
instantiate and create a
delegator for your object.
And then make the API calls
against the Sign-in button.
And more on responding to that
call back-- now I have a user.
Now, the future that was
really exciting to
developers--
especially Android
is the over-the-air install,
which we demoed.
It allows you to push your
Android app directly from your
website, without taking the user
to a different context,
and having it magically
appear on their phone.
With little overhead except for
confirming whether or not
they want to approve
such an action.
It's no more than modifying
your sign-in button.
All you have to do is register
your app package on Google's
API council and in the
Sign-in button.
And we take care of
the rest for you.
And we also make sure that
a user can dismiss it--
that we don't nag them with
multiple prompts if
they don't want it.
And for the user, it
seems natural.
With the sign-in button,
we also make it
pretty easy to register.
Because you can integrate that
button, you can stylize it and
make it look--
along with our branding
guidelines--
natural within your app.
So just looking at
the code, it's
really just a web feature.
So all we've done is added
a new element--
the app packaging.
[INAUDIBLE]
to the Sign-in button.
And that's it.
Once the link's there, we
take care of the rest.
It's partly the dialogue,
and the user
just gets that prompt.
JOANNA SMITH: It should
not be difficult.
And if you are having any
difficulty, let us know
immediately, because it's
probably a simple fix.
And we've probably dealt
with it already.
JONATHAN BERI: The other thing
that I'm showing here too,
which is a little nuance-- we
also support a way to use your
own button.
And this is a very important
feature that, when we were
designing this product, we heard
loud and clear from our
launch partners.
That as long as they can
follow our branding
guidelines, they'd like to use
their own span or stylize the
button in a different way.
So by doing this similar but
different mark up, you can get
that same effect.
JOANNA SMITH: And you
can still use the
over-the-air install.
That ability is not
lost because you
used a custom button.
JONATHAN BERI: Exactly.
And now, the user's signed in.
We also have APIs to take
advantage of the user data
that they've authorized
with you.
And that's where you can
customize your app to add
social data and customization.
You can take their user
profile information--
this is very similar to the
APIs we have today.
Nothing's changed there.
We've now enabled more data.
You can ask the user for their
email, for example--
their age range, their preferred
speaking language.
And you can integrate that into
your application to make
sure that it's welcoming and
it's tailored to them.
You can also use that data for
people in their circles.
So when two people are connected
on Google+ sign into
an app, you can show social
proof and help them discover
contact their friends might be
interested or acting on, and
service that to make it
more discoverable.
Now how to you add that
personalization.
I'm going to run through this
a little bit quickly.
This is a snippet of JavaScript
for anybody's user
APIs today.
It's the same API and points.
The same JavaScript
Client Library.
The same Python Client
Library.
It's the same Java
Client Library.
And it's just now, we get more
data if it's available.
So if you have an integration
today, it's a
pretty smooth upgrade.
Almost no change except
to handle more good
stuff to work with.
On Android, it's again--
you get these from the
connected call back.
You may be able to request a
listener and get the user data
and display that.
And in iOS, very similar.
You do use a Plus service
to go ahead and to get
that same user data.
JOANNA SMITH: So this user
data is still data that
they've made publicly available,
with a few
exceptions.
We include age range
and region.
JONATHAN BERI: Locale.
JOANNA SMITH: Locale.
JONATHAN BERI: So their
preferred speaking language.
And of course there's a separate
a scope for email, is
if the explicitly
request that.
We don't want to give it
away for no reason.
But once you do we, we
also provide you the
user's Google email.
JOANNA SMITH: And we have that
scope in our documentation, so
you don't have to look around
or hunt for it.
It's all very clear for you.
So you can make sure
your development
process is very simple.
JONATHAN BERI: And the neat
thing about scopes in the
Google+ Sign-in experience on
web and Android and iOS is we
combined that into a single
off dialogue.
So if you add another scope
from Google-- for example,
let's say it's Drive
or it's Calendar--
that'll be combined with
the same scope.
It's to be clearly highlighted
what that scope and what data
the user's providing.
And they can choose to approve
or deny that prompt.
JOANNA SMITH: Excatly.
They should not have to sign
in multiple times.
JONATHAN BERI: Now, one of the
newer features-- and one that
we could spend a lot of
time talking about--
is interactive posts.
It's a way to capture users in
the stream with this powerful
call to action that deep links
back into your app.
And it allows you to invite
friends to engage, maybe
connect on their network
or their site or
vote up and vote down.
It also allows you to control
the messaging that's seen in
the stream.
So we talked about
prefilling tags.
We talked about the call to
action, choosing different
labels for that action--
I have a little snippet of
what you have there.
And also because it's
shared on Google+,
we have a rich snippet.
So you can control the text and
the content and all the
description.
And really have your app
presented and make it
appealing for people in their
circles to click back.
Now that deep link is
pretty powerful.
You can control where
the user goes.
And there's a little
bit of nuances.
For example, you could
have a content URL.
So if it's a TV show, the
content URL might be the
station-- or sorry, the
episode, or series.
And the deep link might be
a particular episode.
So the user might want to click
on-- well, I see this
thing for Photo Hunt, but
I'm not quite sure
what Photo Hunt is.
So it'll take them to the
Photo Hunt content URL.
And then if they actually click
on the button, it'll
take them to the deep links and
maybe actually the photo.
JOANNA SMITH: So the user can
really explore your app
through a variety of gateways.
JONATHAN BERI: And definitely,
once they get familiar with
your app and they've seen your
app a few times in the stream,
they'll probably click right
on the deep link and go
directly into your app.
And these are qualified users
who really want to engage.
So the little bit
of code on web.
It is basically an extension
of the share model.
The pop-up that we saw is very
similar to the existing share
box that we have today, through
the share link and
share plug-in.
And now we have one for creating
interactive posts.
JOANNA SMITH: One
thing to note--
even though it is an extension
of the existing share model,
you do need to make sure you
have the plus.login scope,
which is our new scope, in order
to use the interactive
functionality.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
It is [INAUDIBLE] assign it, and
it allows us to do all the
magic of routing and going
cross platform.
But it's a minor delta
to get this enabled.
And then you have to have a
client ID, which is new.
And you can use for us but for
facilitating all that and all
the configuration options-- the
prefilled tax the content
URL deep links, and
things like that.
But otherwise, it's a simple
JavaScript call, and you can
create custom UI to integrate
within your application.
And similarly Android,
it's an intent.
Very simple, straightforward
intent.
It's like our share intent that
allows you to add those
more options.
You create an intent builder,
and you can basically start
that activity on result.
And easy to handle
the response.
So when the user comes back
from the stream, have a
handler for the intent, and then
you can take them exactly
where they intended to go.
Intent for the intention.
JOANNA SMITH: We chose
our words carefully.
Now we're out of synonyms.
JONATHAN BERI: And sharing on
iOS is also very similar.
You just create a shared
dialogue and
you're good to go.
And App Activity is another
feature that we've taken out
of developer preview, which we
previously called History.
But the core of it is allow
you to write activities to
Google about what your users
are doing within your
application.
And then make your app more
engaging, and we engage those
users and take them
back to your app.
We have very simple integration
today, where you
can see all the activities
that you've
done on your profile.
And then depending on how you've
authorized permission,
you can control who sees that.
JOANNA SMITH: And one thing that
we've heard is that both
developers and users are
concerned about the idea of
being viewed as "spammy." And
so the app activities do not
surface on the user stream.
They have their own--
very prominent, but their own
separate part of Google+.
And that's what a user can
go and browse and see
what's going on.
And they can see which App
Activities from their friends
and similar apps that they have,
assuming that all the
promotions have been granted.
And it's a very engaging place,
but separate from the
stream, so nobody feels
overwhelmed by App Activities.
JONATHAN BERI: Exactly.
And if it's one of those--
if you've authorized only you,
for example, you may be the
only one who ever sees this.
So you won't have to worry about
every run you've ever
done or every song you've
ever listened to
show up in the stream.
But if you do have, let's say,
foodie friends, all the
restaurants you go
to might show up.
They can go ahead and see
that on your profile.
I mentioned this as part
of our history preview.
It has now been promoted as
part of Google+ Sign-in.
We've also introduced the
ability to write activities,
read activities, and then
also delete activities.
So really manage the
relationship between your app
and Google, and how it surfaces
to the users.
And writing is just like our
RESTful APIs before, and
native on different platforms.
Simple API call.
This is using JavaScript.
Of course, you can use any of
our support client libraries
and write your own.
On Android, very simple.
You create an ItemScope
builder.
You build it.
And it writes that through
Google Play Services.
So you make that simple
and easy.
In iOS, we have a builder there
too that you can write
for activities.
And a little bit more.
That's it.
That's the 10,000 foot--
what we're launching
for developers.
JOANNA SMITH: Well,
10,002 feet.
Two things I want to say.
One is with disconnect,
we've made it--
one, it's required by our terms
of service that you
offer your users a way
to disconnect.
But if that's hard for them to
find or they don't want to go
into your app, we've made
it really easy for them.
And they can view that at
plus.google.com/apps.
And they can see all of the apps
that they are connected
with, in addition to maybe
controlling which activities
they want to service, or which
ones they might want to
disconnect from.
And a disconnect isn't
permanent.
They can always come back and
re-authenticate into your
application as well.
JONATHAN BERI: I'm actually
going to and
demo that right now.
JOANNA SMITH: So this page is
very simple to get to and very
engaging for the users.
And so you can know that without
too much extra work
from you, they have a clear
way to communicate.
But you do still need to offer
them a way to disconnect in
order to be compliant.
And then the other thing I
wanted to talk about were
Google+ Insights.
And so we have a few new
metrics added to our
analytics, where you can
actually track some of these
new features and see how your
application is getting traffic
or changing the way that the
user's behave because of these
new features.
And so you should definitely go
out and connect your Plus
Page ID with your Dove Console
client ID and your project ID,
and you'll be able to start
seeing these things.
JONATHAN BERI: And they actually
make it really easy.
Go to your Plus page.
You'll see Platform Insights.
You basically get the client--
the profile ID connected
with your project.
And once that link's
established, you can start
seeing all the different pieces
of data that may be
either hard or impossible to
do with existing Analytics,
because it's from deep
within our system.
So over-the-air installs,
interactive posts--
all those.
And those are going to get
better over time as well.
JOANNA SMITH: So we're really
excited to see how this goes.
And we'd love to
hear from you.
Can you think of any other
features we should talk about?
JONATHAN BERI: No.
I think we should
go to questions.
JOANNA SMITH: So we
actually have
several questions already.
And I'm really excited
about this.
And so the first one is
from Paul Erickson.
And I think it's actually
two questions, just
from reading it.
But the first is more abstract,
so I'm going to let
you take it.
Which is, "How does this new
platform affect Google's role
as an identity provider?"
JONATHAN BERI: That's
a good question.
So at Google, we've provided
different identity solutions
for a long time.
Definitely this is the next
big step for Google as an
identity provider.
We think this is going to be
very powerful for developers
to rely on Google as a secure
and safe way to let the users
basically enjoy their apps.
For us, this is basically
our big bet.
We hope you all adopt this as
your Google sign in solution
for Google+ Sign-In.
JOANNA SMITH: And then the
second part of your question--
which was related, but I think
it actually hints at a bit of
confusion--
is wondering about how a
verified identity doesn't
appear to be used consistently
or tied back into things like
maintaining credit card
information or the other
authentication options
that Google offers.
So I was wondering, Jonathan,
do you want to clarify a
little on what a verified
identity means?
What that check mark next
to a profile means?
JONATHAN BERI: So it also
depends on if it's a user or
if it's a page, and
if it's a website.
So verified it just means that
Google has found out if this
is a real user or if there's--
let's say they have
relationship with Google.
They said hey, this
is my account.
There's other people who have
similar names and are
impersonating me.
And for us, that's just to help
users discover the right
celebrity or the right
president.
It's mostly just a flag.
JOANNA SMITH: It's basically
meant to help users so that
anyone who might be confused
or impersonated is covered.
And then one other thing that
I think we should mention
about Google's roles as an
identity provider is that
Jonathan mentioned that
this is our big bet.
And so this is a part of a
really large identity effort
here Google.
Because as some of you
may follow Tim Bray.
And he's mentioned several times
that social is actually
the plural of identity.
And so we are taking great
pains to make sure we can
integrate the two and
do it correctly.
And so we'd love your feedback
as we move forward in this
process, because we want to make
sure we're doing what's
best for our developers
and our users.
So with that, I'm going to
move on to the second
question, which is
really easy.
So this is going to be great.
So Shira wants to know, can you
have the Sign-in button
for a website without the app?
And the answer is yes.
It's just a simple yes.
We support web, iOS, and
Android, either individually
or together in some
combination.
And to some extent, we even
support custom integrations.
JONATHAN BERI: Oh,
that's right.
So one of our launch partners
who is rolling out slowly over
today is Fitbit.
And they've done a pretty
cool integration.
It's kind of web and
kind of not.
Still a lot of Fitbit users
use the desktop client.
It's actually a native desktop
app for Windows and Mac.
And they have an embedded
web view.
It's pretty cool that they can
actually get over the install
working from when a user first
signs up to Fitbit from a
desktop app.
JOANNA SMITH: So I strongly
encourage all of you to check
out our case studies part of
developers.google.com/plus, so
you can see maybe a head start
on how you might want to go
about your integration.
Maybe what features
are most important
based upon our partners.
Because we're really excited
to have partnered with all
these people.
And we want to show you
what they have.
JONATHAN BERI: And hopefully
inspire.
JOANNA SMITH: And several of
them will be coming to visit
on future GDLs.
Spoiler alert.
So Funner Goat wants to know if
they are right in thinking
that an ability to push moments
or App Activities to
the profile is restricted
to Sign-in--
enabled apps on mobile,
not on websites.
And answer is just no.
JONATHAN BERI: It's basically
part of the plus.login scope.
So once the user authorizes
that scope, writing App
Activities is part of it.
Now, you have to explicitly
request an individual App
Activity across all platforms.
Same format.
And then once you have that
permission, you can go ahead
and write moments from web,
from Android, and iOS.
And I think I showed some
snippets for all of those.
JOANNA SMITH: And a good
example is, say
someone's on a news site.
You as a developer could be
writing App Activities for
every time they read
a news article.
And so later, that user can
go back and see the
articles they read.
Maybe find a link that they
thought was interesting at the
time but forgot to
take note of.
And also, you write privately,
but the user can share
whenever they desire.
So there's no risk of spam.
It's just as in the
history preview.
And I think that's
really cool.
So Lars on YouTube wants to know
how much control do the
users have over what data
is given to the app?
JONATHAN BERI: So if you
remembered when I showed that
off dialogue--
within there, of course they
can just dismiss it.
They don't actually have to.
If they try to sign in, and
they see these permissions
they don't want, they
can say no.
And the developer can't keep
on prompting them.
But within that dialogue--
let's look at just the Plus
style login data.
We provide basic profile
information, which is what we
had before.
Profile name, profile
URL, profile pic.
And anything that you've
set public.
So for example, my birthdate
is set public, but my home
address isn't.
So a developer would be able to
actually get my birthday,
because I've exposed that.
Now with additional scope,
such as email--
we provide email, of course.
And the age range and the
preferred language.
And all that falls under our
data retention policy.
You have to keep a fresh cache
of the data, and if the user
disconnects, you have
to delete it.
But the user can go ahead
and change that.
And there's the other part--
that's what you were
about to remind me.
They can also control who from
the people in their circles
that your app can actually
know of.
So they have a full list,
or they can limit
it down to a subset.
JOANNA SMITH: So they pretty
much have control over almost
everything.
I think that the name, the
profile picture, and the age
range and locale are given, but
the language and the name
and profile picture, those are
already very important and
public things anyway.
And the age range
is in a range.
It's not a specific
date or a year.
So they are very protective
there as well.
So Matt?
Nate?
Wants to know if he can use
direct app installs to install
an app that he doesn't own.
JONATHAN BERI: No.
So we protect app developers
from fishing or issues that
they may be impersonated.
Because the app--
the package name-- has
to be both on the
button and in the project.
You can't spoof that.
And there's also an integration
with the Play
store to further
restrict that.
JOANNA SMITH: So no.
So Lars is worried because he
has nightmares still about
those mobsters and farmers
spam that he
got for quite a while.
So how can we reassure him
that won't happen again?
JONATHAN BERI: So at a course of
Google+ is controlling how
broadly and how wide a
user could broadcast.
And with App Activities, we
mentioned that it's contained
within a user's profile.
So it does not go
to the stream.
So every time you-- let's say
you love those farming games.
If a farming game didn't
integrate with App Activities
in Google+ Sign-in, that they
could write all those App
Activities to your profile, but
it wouldn't go into all
your friends' streams.
You can rest assured that your
friends won't be annoyed by
the spam it may be creating.
And actually for apps, you can
talk to developers to say,
hey, this is the wrong type of
App Activity and actually
create a feedback loop.
Especially if it's a mobile app,
by providing reviews in
the Play store.
JOANNA SMITH: I definitely
think so.
So Chris wants know if a call
back can kick off a
server-side process.
And as an engineer, I can tell
you yes, just through XHR.
And we actually have
a lot of samples.
Like I said, they're going
to be coming out today.
And we're moving them to GitHub,
so this is going to be
really great for all of our
developers, if you have ideas
and you're going to start
contributing.
But the one thing you might want
to look at now is we have
a lot of documentation on pure
client-side integrations or a
hybrid client-side server-side
sort of flow.
And you can go ahead and start
exploring all of these things.
So Lost wants to know if the
plus.login scope will become
the default scope for Hangout
apps instead of plus.me.
JONATHAN BERI: So plus.me is not
the default Hangout scope.
There's actually no scope.
But with the power of Hangout
apps-- which is one of my
favorite topics to talk about
besides the new Google+
Sign-in button--
you can add additional scopes.
So we actually have a sample
to be written, or maybe
written by you, to
use plus.login as
part of Hangout Apps.
So think of them as
separate things.
JOANNA SMITH: And on that note,
while we're talking
about Hangouts--
I know many of you have already
noticed we launched
Hangouts version 1.4 recently.
And we're very proud to say that
we're excited about all
the things that are happening
with Hangouts.
And definitely now, with the
launch of Google+ Sign-in,
being able to see integrations
between authentication and
Hangout Apps.
We're definitely looking forward
to what you guys have
the offer coming forward.
So we've reached a lull in the
questions, but we'll probably
hang out for just
a little bit.
I want to go ahead and make one
more announcement, which
is that in 2013, we're pleased
to say we now have three
Google+ Developer experts.
Previously, I know most of you
have already seen Gerwin.
He's been hanging out in all
of our forums and our
community, and he's definitely
one of our more powerful
developers.
And we're really pleased
to work with him.
But adding to his company, we're
now all offering Allen
Firstenberg and Abraham
Williams.
So as you see them in our
Google+ community, or if you
go ahead and look them up on
their own, definitely, you can
trust almost anything that
these guys will tell you.
They are very, very well
informed about our platform.
And we are constantly in
communication with them, and
letting them know what's going
on, and seeing what they have
to offer in their opinions
on our products.
So any time they answer
a question,
you are in good hands.
Don't worry.
JONATHAN BERI: Yup.
Love them.
JOANNA SMITH: I think
that's all of our
questions right now.
JONATHAN BERI: Just to wrap up,
super excited about the
new introduction of Google+
Sign-in and all the APIs.
And the mobile support we've
introduced, and the cool
over-the-air installs.
This is now rolling out today.
And it will be available to
Google Developers broadly.
There's no registration
or sign-up flow.
You just have to create a
project and accept those terms
there, and you're good to go.
And it's supported in all
locations and locales that
Google+ is supported today.
So you can consider this
a global launch today.
JOANNA SMITH: Over 60
something languages?
JONATHAN BERI: That's
about right, yeah.
JOANNA SMITH: So please
get started.
Let us know what you think.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]